welcome back to cbs mornings we have an
update on the record-breaking wildfires
that have burned for weeks in california
you've seen them the caldor fire south
of lake tahoe has covered more than
listen to this 220 thousand acres and
destroyed more than one thousand homes
and other buildings it is one of 14
wildfires burning in the state right now
over the summer fire officials
introduced a new weapon to battle the
flames it's a large helicopter called
the chinook this sunday on 60 minutes
correspondent bill whitaker shows us how
this aircraft could be could be a game
changer in the fight against wildfires
he spoke with the orange county fire
chief
your suppression powers we met brian
fennessy at the truckee airfield about
45 miles from the fires after caldor
destroyed the town of grizzly flats
fenessey volunteered to send his new
firefighting choppers north
more like flying computers with rotors
on top they're called the quick reaction
force fantasy calls the fleet the hammer
this is the hammer so someone calls 911.
you hit it with everything you've got
these big guys and knock it out in case
a fire break glass
the star of the show is the massive
chinook this one used to fly in
afghanistan for the u.s army it's been
retrofitted to fight a different war
dropping water or retardant
now fennessy told us they have this
powerful new tool to take that fight to
the night
the ability to lay retardant line to
continue to drop fire retardant
after sundown that's a first it's going
to change the way you fight fires we
hope so
the chinook can drop 3 thousand gallons
that's about 10 times what most
firefighting choppers drop
lucky us bill whittaker is here in the
studio you got up early thank you bill
please know how much we appreciate it
it's good to have you gorgeous guys
thank you very much that's great yeah
knock on wood so far so good
let's talk about your piece why is this
considered a game changer in the fight
against wildfires
well
first of all it's just the size of this
this chinook i mean it's it's huge it's
enormous and they're able to put a tank
inside the chinook that can drop 3 000
gallons of water or retardant in one
pass
um it's ten times what the helicopters
that you're using today can drop so it's
it's a it's a big change but it's not
just virgo it is more like a flying
computer
not just the capacity it's the
technology what is it about the
technology
well they've taken this chinook and
they've retrofitted it taken all the old
stuff out this is a chinook that the one
that we saw had flown in afghanistan
so they took all the interior out and
they replaced it with everything high
tech you i mean the the
the um
the tank the
the
the cameras they've got um
night vision
goggles and night vision cameras and
everything so they can
can fly this at night
that's the big game changer for this is
like usually
once the sun goes down it's harder to
fight the fire the smoke is thick and
they don't have a way to get in but with
this one with the night vision equipment
they can see through the smoke they can
see at night and they can take this big
chopper with all this water and
retardant and keep fighting the fire
into the night
now bill we were talking during the
commercial break i want to continue this
conversation i went to school in nevada
my mom and dad are in the bay area you
spent most of your adult life in
california
these wildfires are getting worse and
scientists are saying
it is closely
attributed to climate change what have
you witnessed over this time
i worked in the los angeles bureau for
23 years
and in that time i covered
many many wildfires and i will tell you
there used to be a wildfire season
from you know from summer into fall
now
there are forest fires there are
wildfires year round
the the climate has changed
things are drier
it's um you know
the state just doesn't quite know how to
battle
a year-round fire season
just a year you can adjust the
technology to better fight this
individual fire but if you don't address
the underlying problem you're in an arms
race you may not win over time
well the thing with this one is they
they believe that you can go in hit it
hard with a lot of water a lot of power
and
as soon as it starts wipe it out and
stop it from becoming an out-of-control
wildfire so that's what they think these
new choppers will be able to do good to
see you bill whitaker if things have
gone differently you might we might have
seen you on jeopardy
when because i watched you do it when it
was over did you think i want to get on
back to 60 minutes or did you think i
like this
what was that i was glad i have a good
day job
it was fun it was fun
everybody says it's harder than it looks
much harder everybody says it's much
faster i think that's the thing it's
just been it's it's it's very rapid pace
well i'm glad that you are here i'm glad
to be here thank you sir so much thank
you guys thank you very much